hello hello hello and welcome to Sims
and the Left Cove Hendrick is doing
Instagram live as always you can follow
us on Instagram at Sims a love cool yes
you can
Sims you love Instagram I do love
Instagram live it's important to my job
but I don't ever go on it it's very
important so keep looking at it goes
wait so this is I don't even I'm not
even trying to be funny here like I
didn't even I don't think I knew they
had Instagram why you didn't know that I
live now I don't even think I realized
that the social media landscape comes to
take things and run with them so when it
was Facebook live and yeah and Twitter
had periscope and meerkat Instagram does
Instagram like meerkat you never heard
of that well I like meerkats died in
Paris it's like the show Meerkat Manor
here come Adam great stuff great Jay you
ever been around meerkats are pretty
cool
I haven't speaking of animals we do have
our battle coming up later in the show
even though they're not animals versus
Buccaneers we are going to call Phil
Simms a little bit apparently he's at a
commercial shoot yeah for a bank
yes his investor bank commercial you
ever seen that jay-z commercially does
it boomer no never seen it where like
where do you put your money [ __ ] and
dad's like art he wears a green sweater
for investor banking I look good in
green and they will pie would you run
and he goes under on the waggle waggle
it's hilarious so we're gonna invade
their commercial yes and then he will be
judging Patriot versus Buccaneer Sims
will be the patron I will be the
Buccaneer right me and Sims just got
into a furious 45-minute argument about
Kanye West it wasn't an argument we mad
at Kanye West like we've reached a point
where you and I can yell at each other
and afterwards go we're good I got
really nice makes me feel good people in
the office get nervous because we're
like the only people yelling yeah well
we have the biggest mouse in the office
let alone when we're yelling but makes
me feel good you said that man makes me
feel like I'm a part of the tribe that's
a tribe thing right there don't you and
Jewish people argue well just because
you've seen me fend Rick and former
model yeah I only grew up in North
Jersey there was no Jews there I mean
I've never seen any yes of the first
three species on planet I've ever seen
the Instagram commenters were asking
about Adams long ass t-shirt that was
the comment we got damn I like these
long ass to listen is it a sauce it
might be an a so I want to give a shout
out we said on Monday man maybe we
should do our own draft party in New
York right I put it on Instagram put it
on Twitter and the reaction has been so
amazing and you're not on social I'm
talking about people from Macedonia
Austria Argentina Australia Ireland
England Pakistan Jamaica California
Florida everywhere saying I'm buying
tickets let me know guys we were just
putting out the idea but I think it
might have to happen so stay tuned like
um I was watching billions how if you
watch billions and it's you know that
that takes place right in my backyard
right right you know okay you knew that
yeah
well the main guy in billions in I'm
catching up on the second season you
said you know lean into your fear I'm
just gonna put it out there right now
yeah the scary thing when you're doing a
podcast is being like we're gonna do a
live show but people are going to show
up and you're like I I know that
thousands of you guys are like messaging
with a little time but you get scared
[ __ ] being scared man like if we're
gonna do sorry for the curse Joe I think
that we could do events wherever it is
and I really believe that you guys are
gonna show up because I think we're just
creating cool conversations with you
guys and I think that you're gonna show
up because I believe in it yeah so I'm
working towards making this a
possibility I maybe we stage lion vs.
bear life live lion vs. let's dress up
to humans like I don't care about the
humans health you it's a lion fan versus
a bear for dressed up in costume
something in this brain so that was
awesome to see and thank you for
engaging with that we're gonna keep that
going we also got something from John
we're of Nova Scotia Canada that I
wanted to bring to your attention well
mr. weir he was playing Madden oh seven
on his Gamecube with his body
and he ended up randomly with the Bucks
and who was the quarterback Chris Simms
yeah he said that him and his buddy only
don't show him that yet Olli Rehn go
routes with Galloway and they ended up
winning do you care to guess what you
were 25 what was your overall ranking
and Madden so this is a Madden oh seven
yes which is really the O six season
right you're 25 years old yeah so a how
was your overall it has to be a decent
one I'm gonna say I'm a move I don't
want to overstate myself
I'm gonna go 87 you were an 84 I was
your speed 78-63 damn that's a little
love slow now the two most important
ones I had to read message him and say
yo bro it was a throwing power and
accuracy
let's go accurate accuracy first what do
you think you're throwing accuracy was
in Madden Oh seven I'm gonna say that
was an 88 you were an 84 okay you've
literally overshot everything as far and
this is the one where you base so much
of a good ego yes confidence right can
throw it for power less did your
throwing power at mother effers I better
be in the 90s I know that so what do you
think I'm gonna go I wasn't a superstar
so I understand they're not gonna give
me like that 98 I'm gonna say I was like
a 92 you were a 90 throwing 90 ok for
overall 90 throwing power 80 for
accuracy here's the screen shock at that
pic and he said that he knew that Sims
was a lefty but on the first play still
ran a play-action roll out to the right
and went crap literally like what drove
him crazy for the first year if you're
25 and Madden Madden always puts in like
some potential stuff so that if they
play with you in franchise mode you
could improve you yes right right
I mean it's crazy because I actually one
of the years we found that old Madden
like in my closet and my little boy
started playing it because of course I
was in the game so he wanted to build
guys know it got he got sick of it in a
hurry but cuz the graphics the graphics
oh he wants to get into the modern-day
guys but man he said he only ran go
routes with Joey Galloway and that's how
well I gotta think Joey's speed was
probably like a 97 or 98 code fast
Joey's was superhuman our number for
today's episode is sixty three sixty
throughout before we do that I'm gonna
give a shout out to Daniel Jacobs
you love them I do one is boxing match
on Saturday hoping he can get a rematch
with triple G or something like that and
we know they go we're gonna go then i
targeted a but wasn't the Saturday after
the draft where I think we've never done
it we were dead tired I just couldn't
even beat cancer but no doubt about 63
any 63 is kind of 63 the first one that
comes to mind is Gene Upshaw yes yes one
of five Hall of Famers that I found
wearing 63 v Hall of Famers that's a
good one for me okay so wait all right
so the 63 I always go to my dad's team
Carl Nelson was a 63 I don't know I know
you don't have him on there but wait
this is gonna turn 63 so Brandon Fusco
Corey Linsley and Antonio Garcia the
Patriot okay random ones that I like 63
from the Eagles was Hank Fraley
he loves them all thank free Wayne
Robertson he had top five pick from the
New York Giants
tackle were 63 at a Kentucky random guys
in the 90s and 2000's Jeff Saturday
right do you think he's gonna be a
hall-of-famer oh he's gonna be close
Manning will definitely factor yes Dan
Connolly Joey and drewsy Barret Robbins
man Super Bowl Fame yeah Brad Meester
and Roberto Garza okay don't tell me the
Hall of Fame ops all right
Hall of Famer Tampa Bay Oh
Elvin Elvin right right exactly right
Pittsburgh damn Oh offensive line I know
I'm not gonna be able to Cal call it go
ahead Mitchell's RDD Duke Doss I mean
know who is it all right there yeah sir
Monty's no I said yes all of Fame
Houston Oilers offensive line
Oh Mike Munchak Mike munch munch I
forgot he was 63 my old coach yeah and
then a linebacker I didn't write down
what team he's on Willie Lanier Oh
Willie near this Chiefs right when they
were when he's Super Bowl three and our
four and beat the Minnesota Vikings d3
is interesting because it's giving us
off
of Lyman defensive line linebackers it's
in a weird right it's covered a lot of
baby it is I would never pick 63 if
would you ever pick 63 if Aaron often
sword even so I know one number that you
wish Sam darn old wouldn't pick I was
just about to ask if you're gonna break
you know I know and he picked 14 he
think we a lot of people going
I was literally listening to the podcast
and then heard Sims go I hate 14 and
then he comes on yeah I know I mean it's
his number so he's identifiable there it
shows you he's certainly not as scared
of the history the number four team of
the New York Jets so why did you say
what is the history what do you not like
about let's see it's Richard Todd Wright
who has really had a decent career with
the Jets but it's famous for throwing
five interceptions an AFC championship
game to lose to the Dolphins who the
Dolphins that went on to lose to the
49ers and that Super Bowl right so that
was another one where way I'm missing
another 14 to hold on there's there's a
few of them doesn't know the history has
not been written yet and that he can
kind of yeah that's what he's he's
fearless is that he doesn't care is that
actually something you would care about
the history of a number on a team like
if you went to the box to I would know
that our holder that dropped a huge kit
yeah my point was just that 14 ugly that
looks very square it is it just doesn't
and really who's the greatest 40 never
like think of a fort I'd ever
I mean it's quarterback he's a squarish
Donald was 14 for the Jets and then
there's another 14 I'm blanking on right
now damn there's a Glen that's not Glenn
Foley he was in 14 Sam's a squarish
looking guy too so it only accentuates
his squareness
they were saying that Sam darn old looks
like a lego policeman it does a little
bit all right so the way that I always
do this I go to Pro Football Reference
you searched the number and then they
have a way in which they see relevancy
I'm typing in 14 okay I'm researching
the most number one is Dan Fouts yeah oh
damn a quarter two is Ken Anderson okay
those are the two probably best 14
Brad Johnson Andy Dalton Richard Todd
Neil O'Donnell Ryan Fitzpatrick it's not
a great number Brian Griese and I guess
yy8 it'll may have worn other numbers as
well why I sent a war 14 with the Giants
you know what else other number why to
the war 63 with the Baltimore Colts City
number and it brings us all back back to
more numbers in the NFL NFL Network
guess what just started coming out o the
top 100 I'm already seeing Malcolm
Jenkins and people getting upset that
they're ranked in the 90s we had a lot
of people say what are we gonna do a
Simza left go 100 it's more work for you
so I'm gonna ask you live Chris has
nothing to do right now the drafters
over that's right yeah no I know yeah
yeah ranked some ditch it's more fun to
go manly enough Oh 100 sucks
what making the honey I don't think
people realize is is voted on the
players and I would say half the players
in the league don't even really get to
watch the other half in the league
during the year yeah you know if you're
if you're I'd say half of that half
don't actually watch no know exactly
right exactly
or there some of those half that don't
go home and watch him on that night
football they don't care they play
football they love it and they're
probably gonna just vote for their
teammates or yes or they're just gonna
vote for a common mainstream name but I
mean this is one thing I think with
coaches and players that goes on every
football season and this is why I think
I have a relationship with some coaches
in the NFL because you're playing your
division the division you're playing in
your conference and then the crossover
division and the AFC your NSE right so
there's like five divisions you're never
paying exactly right and I mean that's
one of the during the seasons one of the
most common questions I get from my
coach right so someone that watches yeah
do you want to undertake this no so
we're just gonna I think if Simms did it
the quarterbacks would be way lower than
people would expect because you always
tell her value the quarterback the
quarterback so value and I think you
would have more interesting positions in
the top lot was on the list again and
it's like he played like two games yeah
and then like the last two years telling
us right I will say though that all the
players that are like I can't believe on
this low there are 1700 players and
and you made the top 100 like Malcolm
Jenkins I know that you think you're
better than 95th but like yeah I don't
let's be happy who cares the other
number that I want to talk about is Big
Ben Big Ben last year before the season
I don't know guys I might would have
hang it up soon well now that they've
drafted mason rudolph i want to play
three to five more years yeah fire is
back right so there's two ways to look
at this either one Ben just shut up like
like oh like if he comes back in shape
this year then I'll be like whoa but is
there anything to patrick mahomes comes
into camp fuels Alex Smith Alex Smith
has the best year he's had right if
Mason Rudolph comes into camp and is
able to challenge been at all which I
don't think he's the physical prowess of
my home try to intimidate someone right
could we get a bet a better been because
of this I do think this will make Ben
you know get on his you know what do I
want to say just dot his eyes and cross
his T's a little bit about his overall
game just to go okay wait there it's
legit now they are looking starting to
look at people who replace me it's that
time in my career I think the big thing
is what you said for he's never gonna
feel threatened once he gets on the
field with them right so that's the
biggest thing where my home's Alex Pitts
was like oh man this guy's got a lot of
talent he gets on the field that makes
three or four throws I'm never gonna get
on the field again and you don't think
Mason's gonna listen I don't think so
Ben is one of those people too and I
know I've told this story before and
you've heard me say just when you see
him in person you go first of all whoa
he's big and then you go man that mf'er
can he can throw that ball holy crap I
mean that's what it takes you guys is if
somebody comes on the field and and can
really rip it right you're gonna go yo I
need to get everything tight cuz I'm not
just gonna overthrow and he's gonna
overthrow Mason usually right and he's
already know Ben's like he's a diva out
of all the quarterbacks we say this all
the time he's definitely Deva he's
definitely a you can't tell me I can do
this well I'm gonna do it think about
that even things that Ben Roethlisberger
has done right we're not even talking
about the early on disgusting Georgia
accusation I'll talk about recently
calling out martavis Bryant as he's
coming out of rehab and saying that he's
been a distraction
openly fighting with Todd Haley and
getting Todd Haley in essence fired
right showing up to camp wearing a
baseball hat and just like knocking
things down and be like I don't need to
do with all this stuff
threatening to retire in order to like
be taken more seriously in contract
stuff like Ben is very much a diva yeah
but because he rocks a backwards hat in
place for Pittsburgh he's blue-collar
Ben yeah he is so white-collar like like
diva spoiled Dave diva spoiled him there
in Pittsburgh he's been allowed to get
away he's never who's the biggest backup
to threaten them it's been Bruce Grant
Kowski and Landry Jones yeah right maybe
match was there we're back up yeah and a
guy that openly talks about maybe
leaving to become a pastor at a time and
Landry Jones right there's no
competition phone
they brought Michael Vick in I mean but
yeah you're right there's been no
competition for him he's one of those
guys I mean his talent is pretty top-end
I don't think you have to worry about
like massaging his ego and then I played
against Jacksonville it was his best
game maybe in the last four years this
is the way he is I mean yeah it's not
forget even to either that list he got
in a motorcycle accident before practice
I mean he's done a number of things
where you go like damn man what are you
doing but you're but but I know a lot of
sighs he's in the conversation too for
me I'll say this and the people on there
I think he's in the conversation from
one of the 10 greatest quarterbacks in
the history of the sport he's in the
condo I'm not saying he's Devon it's a
potential amici's dance has he earned
the right to do all of those things
two-time Super Bowl winner yeah
future hall-of-famer possible top-ten
quarterback of all time if there's any
guy that can push out an OC or call out
a wide receiver get into a motorcycle
accident I mean I don't think anybody
ever earns the right to do any of that
stuff like those were our Konya
conversation well I just don't think you
were I don't like like I mean Tom
Brady's earned the ability to do more
than Ben Roethlisberger but that's not
what he's gonna do because it's not the
right thing and because again the coach
runs a team there and it's not his job
to be a bigger spectacle than Bill
Belichick over the New England Patriots
let's get to Tom Brady yeah I see a clip
online and there he is
Tom Brady sitting next to Jim Gray and
Jim Gray asked if he thought appreciated
by the Peach
and Tom Brady like a robot Tom Brady to
me it was like a politician that's
trying to convince you that he's normal
Tom Brady goes hmm I plead the fifth
and it was so canned and it was so
meticulous that you know that him and
Jim Gray worked on it beforehand and my
first question was how is Jim Gray still
getting these things Jim Gray's his
great personal friend that's where that
has to start with what you're saying
yeah it's his great personal friend then
I would guarantee that Tom Brady
wouldn't sign on to do it unless Jim
Gray was me Jim Gray was gonna do
something and then everybody laughs I
don't know why you're laughing it wasn't
that funny
but after Jim Gray did that thing with
LeBron and it completely backfired right
I just don't understand how Jim Gray
still get in these well why is he why do
you think athletes are going I trust Jim
Welch it because he's easy to trust if
you know Jim Jim this is like salt of
the earth good guy he really is he's now
yeah reporter from my dad and CBS early
on and my dad's career there so now NBC
I should say it wasn't even CBS of his
NBC yeah so he has incredible
connections everywhere that broke the
Dickerson thing like yeah it had like 30
40 years of breaking news I just didn't
understand after LeBron I thought if you
pitched it to LeBron every other athlete
pitch afterwards I thought would fall
through yeah because it backfired
completely I hear you I know but I don't
think anybody looks at that and blames
it on Jim Gray I think that Tom Brady is
corny er than Russ Wilson wow that's
pretty
that's a bold I don't think he is I know
what you mean I mean Brady anybody
listen I think all these famous like
when you're super super famous you're
really just protecting your ass you're
you're like you're not reality the world
is not it's not even comprehensible I
think to me who's been around somebody
like my dad because my dad's not even on
the status of a Tom Brady or anything
like that right so truly the world is a
different world for them in all facets
and they are not in the reality of a
normal world nor is their family and as
much as they want to try to be normal
and I think Tom doesn't do a good job of
trying to be a normal dad
and all that his day-to-day life is just
not normal I mean there's nobody else
living his life and on this planet other
than like Ronaldo just fancy camels in
Qatar everyone's right working out on
the beach so also the pressures and the
magnifies right if you were to say
something out of line it would blow up
he's in and tom is a guy that we've seen
he wants people to like him it's
obviously somewhat important to him but
yeah I'm with you that seemed staged he
didn't have to say that but it goes into
the whole thing again that listen
there's a rift there I mean this is this
is this is definitely a rip between
Belichick and Brady I'm not gonna say
it's gonna go down as like a fight it's
not gonna really affect 2018 season
they're still back in the playoffs would
be awesome I don't even doubt that it
does
Brady feel underappreciated by Belichick
definitely sure he said he'd flash to
help I think everybody in general wants
to be appreciated more at work in their
professional life the people that I work
with are trying to get the best on them
right I mean there's nobody that has an
owner that appreciates Tom Brady more
than that all right I mean come on
Robert Kraft literally tells him how
cute and handsome he is and kisses him
before the game I mean oh you're so blue
blue uniform remember after week one
last Jets what he said to him no that
was a Thursday night game a few years
ago thing Robert Kraft is jealous that
Tom Brady kisses his kids on the mouth
but not him but either way what was my
point
oh this is my other point with this so
there's obviously the rift Brady does
say that and he's taking a little yeah
underhanded punch at Belichick and all
them certainly does he feel
underappreciated yes and I understand
that he probably gets to him but he did
clarify it too and saying the main point
right exactly right Bill Belichick job
is not to go Oh Tom your sweet love you
you're so appreciative here you're so
good oh my gosh you know what happens
when you do that you become rg3 okay and
then you go oh damn well good I don't
have a backbone or any toughness or I
can't handle criticism so Bill Belichick
the years I was there right Wes Welker
couldn't I mean you could tell there was
days where I was like John I think he
wants to go over the practice field
right now beat the [ __ ] out of Bill he
wants to beat him up he wants to beat
him up but the coaches would always tell
me like build things that Wes performs
better when he's a little angry and he
feels like he's got
upon his shoulder and everything like
that and that's what Bill did bill when
they retire Bill's gonna tell Tom how
awesome he is and how appreciative is
but for now he's the quarterback of the
team and Bill wants to win and he don't
give a damn about Tom's feelings
bill washe wasn't that nice to Joe
Montana when they were winning four
Super Bowls either I don't know if joe
Montana's still likes Brian I don't
think he does
so exactly right I mean Bill Parcells
and I want to be like why I don't even
like Bill Parcells that much and I
didn't even know also do you want to win
Super Bowls or do you want to have a
coach that likes you guys doing
something right it's worked for 15 years
so what this is to me is it's two things
the sports fans at us go that's why Bill
Belichick is great the human danesco I
know what it's like to have a boss that
doesn't yes yes and so what happens is
is we kind of empathize more with Tom
Brady the other thing is this because
they lost the Super Bowl and because the
major question mark was Malcolm Butler
which Tom Brady also talked to mess it's
we can we can question the
decision-making of Bill Belichick which
then allows all of these players the
Amendola 'he's the Gronk's the Brady's
to go see he's not perfect he's telling
me all the time and he's not perfect
right but the true thing is is they
almost won the Super Bowl without
Malcolm Butler they hung up 33 on the
Eagles defense was like the number one
defense in the in the country right so
for me I think it's interesting to watch
all of these players go man I hate him I
hate him I hate him and then when you
lose the Super Bowl they're coming after
him the reason that I love Bill
Belichick he's not gonna be harder on
Tom Brady he's not gonna be harder on
Grunk he's gonna be the same guy so I'm
glad that all these dudes are getting
this out of their system because when
they go to training camp you're still
running the hill at the end of practice
Tom he's still saying that the high
school quarterback can come in here
right you are battling a robot and I'll
say this now I love Doug Peterson I
would trade Doug Peterson for Bill
Belichick in a second yeah because he's
the best yes he's the best right I mean
I love Doug Peterson - you're right
there's there's no denying it but yeah
yeah I mean it's the site would trade
Tom Brady for multiple quarterbacks but
I would treat Bill Belichick for noble
yeah
so this is like the players getting all
this frustration
yeah but guess what you're getting back
there and it still bills rule yeah and
if you talk this crap in the middle of
the year I bet you Brady don't let us
say that she's in the middle you're not
don't know we talked about this the day
after the draft with Noah of how much
he'd paid Bill Belichick versus how much
he would take it away yeah yeah and I
would pay bill I would pay Bill
Belichick thirty million dollars yeah
he's worth it
I mean if Kirk Cousins I know there's no
coach in all of sports that has more of
an impact on their team success right
bill balance and then I would also say
there's not Popovich no not not and then
the sport itself lends itself to coach
coaching is more important in football
than any of the other sports I
understand it's important in basketball
and baseball don't get me wrong but
football is truly a chess match yes and
there's so many different players and
schemes and matchups on a week-to-week
base bet basis balancing your roster the
salary cap all that the coach is
extremely important and bill does two
jobs
he's GM - yeah probably does eight jobs
I say three but yeah you're right I mean
he's GM he's gracious right exactly
right he's like and he's also like the
operations guy for the New England
outing we're gonna leave the but the
buses are gonna leave at 3:30 on on for
our seventh game of the year when we
travel to New York
he's probably mean they got the schedule
ready he's probably got again he's
probably got next year's draft it pretty
much under control already it's 420 420
call Phil Phil is on the set of a
commercial have to ask I think it's
investor bank I don't want to screw this
up I hope I'm not giving some excited to
hear his voice yeah they're not paying
us know screw it up all you want yeah
you're right screw them they're
commercial they're paying him but Phil
for this podcast meetings do you want to
guess the most sold jerseys of the NFL
Draft YZ okay say Quan one he was 100
del was right Sam Donald - same door
knob was three okay
Shaquille your Fanta was five okay
the other two are quarterback another
Baker Mayfield - and then I guess it's
going to have to be Lamar Jackson nope
Josh Allen yes so it goes c'est quoi one
Baker - Sam Donald three Josh Ellen four
Shekinah Griffin five that's cool like I
said man and I think Shekinah is going
to over
take say Quan when like the 60 minutes
story start happening they go to camp
and he's doing with his brother and then
like you got like that country ESPN
reporter be like man I just love the way
that you guys play - Marty did you see
the video of John Schneider and Pete
Carroll calling Shiki I'm halfway
through he like emotionally got all
emotional about that video okay you call
but let us hear the voicemail and will
just leave him a voicemail he says he's
ready so call love you yeah I think part
of the thing that we do here that's
great is we ask good questions and we
leave good voicemails and if you're
ready for it he's your name oh well I'll
just
Aki go and quit Nelson Chris Balor
brought in a bunch of media people to
show why he drafted Quinton Nelson and
he showed the first thing he did was him
doing a free standing squat and showed
that at 325 he's able to get his butt
lower than his knees and then he showed
him touching his toes on the ground and
he was able to bend further than some
gymnasts and he looked at the reporters
and he said God made him a little
different than anybody else
that's yeah that position is very
important I mean yeah Bend exactly right
I mean I can remember when when the
Patriots were workout offensive linemen
yes score Nekia
would make them do these like stretching
drills and see what they and I was
always like what the hell is he doing
like I've met and I know the players
were like what what am i doing my toes
and he's making me bend over in these
weird positions but and it's real
there's a correlation of their
flexibility in Bend definitely it is and
of course for scar Nekia was a very
important so he wasn't gonna let valuate
any offensive lineman without see him do
some of those things
I sent Quinton Nelson our conversation
about Irsay hey Quentin what's up man
and he was dying he was not quit Nelson
I think is gonna be just my buddy I
that's alright it's a good buddy that
has gonna be a future all you ever get
in a fight he's the guy you call is Phil
there no where are you is Nick there
Nick are you back there are we flying
solo right now me what is gonna be
flying with no pilot I heard
anybody producing this show oh god
you're so high-tech a new age you can't
even get them on a phone you're right I
don't believe they gave us no resources
for the show today dad because one guy
in the back doing everything big Phil
let me hear Shelton Nick big Phil let me
hear what is your lines in this
commercial practice with us well we
don't have a Boomer Esiason and myself
and Brian Nelson who works for Young
Dhabi the company represents us we're
sitting in a room waiting and I don't
think we I think we have to do the
facial expressions
oh so bloomers gonna you know well you
know this is me Josh and Adam yeah we
were just living there making fun of me
Monday morning on their show how I talk
to myself and this and that and because
we did that draft cell together right
this is investor Bank right we're today
we're doing a commercial for investors
thank you investors bank so you guys are
gonna run the waggle waggle together and
you know talk about those kind of things
again no no no this is really cool they
they got smart after the last one they
agree mrs. little talking as possible
good yeah so we're just walking through
lobbies I'm holding boomers hand who's
in better shape these days he is fit
back said that to me and I actually
we've said to support I went home and
looked it up in the dictionary and
there's no such thing
they're like four-year-olds there for
anything to it I had to kind of like
punching and they're gonna show the past
what hitting people's coffee cups and
all this stuff and I just my line is you
never could handle the pressure or
something like you know I love them but
I was pretty good Chuck at him you know
whatever it was he took his shirt off
last night is like it's all bruised back
at the frat house like children happy
we're like like grumpy old men they just
can't get away from each other the
production company and the bosses I
think they said around and go and if
these morons would just do we tell them
we could get done here quicker in a
minute they actually sent the roster I
eat it out and says hey you two gotta
settle down quick you know whatever so
Phil I know that you've been sitting
since the draft and I'm curious what's
like the main thing that you took away
from the drift that you haven't been
able to talk about let's get it out here
in the open
oh geez you kind of caught me by
surprise here I guess I'm tearing up in
my eyes just laughing doing all this
with John oh no Johnny had a good draft
quarterbacks were all interesting where
they went so I think that you Pavarotti
talked about it to guys Josh Allen and
Sam Donald I think they should start
from day one
hmm get them in there practice them and
just give them all the reps and all that
stuff just let it go
yep so you know that that would be you
know the we're gonna wait till he's
ready no this we've got two teams that
are not going to the Super Bowl so use
all your resources and year one as soon
as you can just to get their money so
your team and both teams have you know I
think good futures if these quarterbacks
come through you know they've done a
good job of free agent acquisitions
that's a good draft pick so that'd be
the part of one thing I really haven't
talked about the draft
nobody called me because what the hell
but I know right yes well we're doing
you now we're milking yes yeah okay
there's another question there Bluebird
in the mornings has me down pretty good
he-he'll Aviva's killing me so he was
imitating me so did you go ahead what go
ahead yeah you go I was just gonna say
what I wanted I don't even think I've
really talked about this with dad either
just Baker may feel that one right yeah
were you shocked by it did you believe
it when you were hearing the rumors that
it might be real yeah kind of give us
your reaction I never thought it was
real probably didn't really believe it
but I guess until about finally a day
before since nobody released any
information about it that he is going to
go on and I just said okay and I know
this is there's a certain stigma but it
goes to the number one pick of the draft
but if he's gonna be picked number three
in a dress what's the difference if
you're one or three so you know it kept
hearing oh maybe he would go to the New
York Jets two three so if he goes one
two Cleveland what's the big deal if
these so does that make sense so cold
water class right and I think there was
a bigger deal made of that because he
was the first ticket to draft and
because you know deep down all of us
really thinking if you're six foot you
just gonna have a hard time have a great
success in the NFL yeah I mean the thing
that's just to follow up with that the
thing that's crazy about it to me and
just the the answer is that they've
given unto this point seems like they
drafted him a lot on just because of his
ability to communicate and be a leader
in the locker room but the number one
compliments that I'm hearing coming out
of Cleveland is one
he's got like a photographic memory
right he can remember everything right
who we love the way that he can lead and
well I do it to Chris Sims litmus test I
have heard no one talked about his arm
strength or his accuracy Yeah right I
hear everyone talking about him the
person right which when you don't start
the conversation about the physical
ability in the field that it's always
scary to me at least as an evaluator or
somebody that talks about
sport well-nigh told me always talk
about we always talk about that exactly
the exact thing you know don't tell me
all those intangibles and everything
else you know give me some meat right
now tell me something that I can hang my
hat on and and if we got something to go
forward with you know and there they are
in Buffalo at number 12 they move up to
get Josh Allen and I do an article it
was out there yesterday I think it was
yesterday maybe today I don't know when
but and that they're all unhappy all we
should have took roles in this so you
know everybody's gonna great no matter
what that pressure is and who you do of
whatever and I was just one wow I
thought Buffalo would be a static the
fans yeah they get Josh Allen but I
guess they bought into all the stuff
they heard the whole time word you know
it's not accurate and bloom on the
helmet yeah that's the emblem on the
helmet it just doesn't make feet people
feel as cozy as seeing a UCLA or USC or
an Oklahoma that you know yeah well no
when the live bullets through that's
alright so we got something fun all
right so Phil you're having to do
another mascot battle between me and
Christopher if you want to get boomer
into judge as well we can do them okay
so the battle today
your son is representing a patriot and I
am representing a Buccaneer who would
you like to hear from first Wow I'd lost
last time yeah he remembered the dolphin
beat Paul Broun he was Paul Brown last
time all right so
Phil I just want to explain to you that
a Buccaneer is a pirate of the Caribbean
and they follow no laws so unlike a
patriot I can fight beyond the whistle
the Patriots they go to a result the
Buccaneers they love to fight boomer do
you want the fighter needing a check or
just wanting the bell to ring I'll ask
you that first number two Buccaneers
were French Dutch and English
adventurers who turned to piracy they
were the worst of the worst from
everywhere the Patriots were really only
the semi worst from one region of the
country or the world excuse me and I'll
end up with this the
Buccaneers excellent marksman the
reputation precedes him and they hunted
wild boars for food I don't know what
Patriots did but I'll tell you what they
kind of lived in the lap of luxury and
Buccaneers were brutal Oh turn the floor
over now to a patriot Wow
so so nicely said for the uneducated
Buccaneers of the world who were pirates
at sea who were just I am their lawyer
I'm representing them just they're a
lower class of human being than a
patriot okay I mean yes I know they were
in their lap of luxury up there saving
America from and making them free and on
horses with their muskets and their cool
hats and all that but this is a
well-thought-out individual who has
plans to overtake countries not like oh
we're gonna rub some ship out in the
Caribbean no we go around land we're
gonna go no luck well they can't come
into our land because we're the Patriots
and we have laws on these lands so we
don't even need a closer those laws
don't apply to us
that's great but the jail will when we
throw them in there then we'll see how
they do
it's like fortunate because you'll be in
jail or dead you did and then you're
talking about a marksman what Buccaneers
don't even have guns okay their sword
fighters I've done the research and
Patriots we know get a musket and they
can shoot from distance right and they
got a horse to ride on if you get off
the boat you're just on foot buddy the
number one the number one plane
Buccaneers distracting people with their
boats and having already landed so they
would have landed in Virginia and then
storm north I think we've got enough
points out there Phil okay what is your
verdict enough information it's way too
much information or pain to comprehend
I'll just say this you know we talk
about all that intangibles and in the
NFL for quarterbacks well that holds
nothing here in this this little battle
so I are in holds a lot this well I
should say so I'm taking the picture cuz
he's just smarter and more conniving and
there's nothing better on his feet right
so there's a reason why these guys are
[ __ ] ears and pirates right they were
right low wonderful scores very low
wonderful scores following
I would love nothing more than to pick
against ghosts appropriate thank you Dad
this is nonsense
but apparently I might not have lost to
talk to my healthy-looking friend over
here over I'm doing great man you bother
I don't know how you deal with it man he
is truly like he's 8 years old
honestly I think that you had not given
PTSD to be honest really honest he has
no idea what he's doing what he's
talking what he's talking about
we went to what place and who's got what
intangibles and all that crap you have
any idea well we heard you had PT PTSD -
because Francesa just rejoined the WFAN
we do have an app to be on we used to
interview boomer all the time from his
office yes and it would be come on you
nitwits hurry up with you guys you guys
are really good together and you need to
get on you know you need to be out there
a little bit more than you are you're
not out there we resent the notion here
that Bleacher regard the neck neck neck
boomer is saying it boomer well so
what's going on in your world babysit
your dad here the last two days and
being the ultimate professional that I
am you know got to work the radio show
every single day you know I got to do
the draft with your dad and your dad
that was like born for him so into it
watches all the film a more peripheral
guy I'm a big-picture guy right now I
want to see certain quarterbacks in
certain places and
no I felt like Josh Allen should have
gone to Buffalo or Cleveland that Baker
may feel was been great for the Jets and
Donald great for the for the Giants and
of course I think a lot of us had Josh
Rosen gone to the Cardinals I think a
little bit earlier than he ended up
going but at the end of the day I think
ended up in the right place yeah you're
happy with what the Giants and Jets did
I know you got to talk about that so
much on the radio show all the time but
especially your jets I mean yeah you you
see you see a future for Sam darn old
right hey Chris think about this yeah
when I probably played quarterback from
the age of nine years on right right
this kid has basically played the
position of quarterback since you were
16 years old he is 20 he will be 21 in
June think about the fact that he was a
linebacker his hoary became a
quarterback he was a great basketball
player and he's just barely scratching
the surface as a quarterback so I don't
necessarily know how you know how a
successful he'll be in his first year
but if he continues on this trajectory
and he ends up being a big hit for the
Jets they're going to end up investing a
half a billion dollars in this kid over
the next 20 years so yeah I I he's a
nice kid he's a really just a tremendous
character kid you know I love all of his
interviews all of his ex-teammate say
all these great things about him I just
hope he doesn't get swallowed up with
all the negativity and all the
expectations that kind of hit him right
here in the face over the next six
months right I have a question
boomer what's up bro about say Quan
because half of us which is me and Sims
go this guy is so special I'm so excited
for the Giants they got them and there's
like this other half of people that are
like you're never taking running back
that high this is crazy and I'm just
curious guy that's seen now like a
number of decades of football how do you
process that discussion well I you know
it's more of a priority thing I honestly
believe it was more political for the
New York Giants that they didn't take a
quarterback ya know I certainly thought
that Donald's going to the Giants in the
incubator that is Pat Shermer and Eli
Manning over the next few years and then
resigning Odell Beckham to a big
contractors and
gonna have to pay Eli Manning that entry
or so made a lot of sense for me but to
me like the Mehra family basically told
whoever was going to run this franchise
that Eli Manning was going to be the
quarterback for as long as Eli Manning
wants to play yep so in order to do that
you do not want to bring a guy in that
is so high-profile this early in the
draft so you support your quarterback
Eurasian quarterback with a new left
tackle hopefully a healthy Odell Beckham
jr. and a super stud running back so I
understand why they did what they did I
certainly don't agree with it long term
but you know these things you know have
a way of finding them with themselves
through and we'll find out pretty
quickly whether or not they've gentlemen
did the right thing here for the charge
you were you're the man the man boom
punch that guy and say it's from his son
punch him right in the storm and go that
we actually need to ask Phil a question
from Deirdre so if we can get Phil back
really quick this is a good one boom man
you know he was too nice nice boomer
don't be that guy that's on oh hey Phil
this is this is Josh so just you know
we're starting to plan our draft
coverage for next year we're thinking
about doing a party somewhere 30 the
public can come to your daughter Deirdre
sent us a message and said throw the
party at big Phil's house
he's got the space food and drinks I'll
plan the whole thing what are your
thoughts on a draft party at your house
next year okay that was easy so wait we
can get like a few a few hundred Sims
and left go fans to come over we are
gonna do the draft somewhere live next
year we there's a calling from the
people so we are gonna do it and then
your daughter of course she'll she
donated your money
your house have support the idea okay
she thinks it's her off anyway we just
wanted to hear your reaction alright
and then and you're coming in in the
next few weeks yes we want you in person
well I'll be next couple weeks I'm
finally getting done here and everything
so it's gonna settle down after next
week so I will come in and well I don't
know what we'll talk about yeah don't
worry it's our show we'll figure it out
appreciate you Phil Kings pass on this
commercial man earned some money for our
draft party next year I said earn some
money for our draft party next year
alright see you dad alright there was no
fight come to the Simpson left go draft
party at big Phil's house yes that's an
event Oh that'll be a vet serious he
could yeah I he would be he is serious
so like where he'd think about it now
when we lay out the details we'll say a
few hundred random cars right right he
does not realize what he's getting
himself into that would be incredible it
would be he does have to set up for it I
mean dad has got a great a great house
in my old hometown Franklin Lakes in
Franklin Lakes New Jersey New Jersey
town all right we got the venue settled
perfect alright you get the invitations
Sims you make a playlist okay by the way
yeah love that you did that with
Francesa with boomer is it legitimate
hatred right now I don't know if it's
legitimate
I mean if boomer has been phenomenal
it's sticking up for the people at W I
think yes do Francesa has taken a lot of
shots at I don't think people so I
didn't realize what Francesa was until I
came to New York I had heard clips of
him I of course heard of him but he is
the voice of New York sports him and the
mad dog had a show that will change
sports radio forever right in
Philadelphia I listen to Howard askin
Josh vendrick literally grew up on
Francis he goes on an 18-month
retirement tour leaves for three months
and now he
back on the station and kick some people
off ephedra do you still love the guy
yeah he didn't kick anyone off he just
their show is now only two hours instead
of four and a half seems you were up for
his job we're up for the job that was to
replace him yes I'm a good thing I'm
glad I didn't take it and I I have a lot
of I don't like what Mike Francis is
doing plain and simple I don't think
there's any really other way to do it
this is what I think bothers me about it
left go a little bit he's been so
critical of personalities and people who
are disruptive to their sports
organizations here in New York whether
that's Odell Beckham jr. more than Matt
Harvey's of the world
oh they're divas oh they're spoiled just
shut up and do your job and yet he left
wfn I mean just complaining ranting
they're running this business into the
ground
the idiots from CBS sports don't know
what they're doing the the heads of WFAN
or a bunch of idiots disgruntled mad at
them and then okay he retires right
retires can't find the job anywhere else
really that's gonna pay him anything to
what his ego wants right or what he was
getting and then he calls back the new
company that buys wfn there's a new
company running it now and goes over the
WFAN people's heads and goes to the
president of this new company that owns
WFAN and basically begs back for his job
and that they need him and whatever else
and they put him there and I think
that's just what bothers me more than
anything because I've heard him all last
football season leading up the season
drawing out just oh I mean and here he
is it's been the disgruntled complaining
employee who's making city was making
like six and a half million dollars or
WFAN he speaks no facts almost on the
radio he just jibber jabbers but that's
what y'all love that's what I've never
understood in France I love him because
it's a cult following cuz they like him
because of what he is they followed him
growing up when he had brains and he had
insight and he had connections in the in
the sports world he does not have any of
those anymore has that changed for you
yeah it's just entertainment this thing
to the kids just yeah it's a character
it's like your teen falls asleep on the
microphone it's all part you know
somebody says like
three great points and he can't argue it
he just calls him an idiot and hangs up
I mean the u.s. always like the amount
of times that Francesa blows up on
insert topic yeah it spread on the
Internet right I'm like you guys are
still getting excited about him calling
out a caller as an idiot so I'm just
gonna give you your your headline right
now Chris Simms : quote Mike Francesa is
the Odell Beckham of WFAN you can see
that in the New York Daily News tomorrow
well pretty good I'm actually gonna say
that I'm curious if this happens to him
yeah is this very Jay Leno Conan O'Brien
right the difference is that Jay Leno
never talked crap about Conan O'Brien he
just behind that to it he went on the
radio with Mike Mad Dog right on Syria
and trashed the three people that took
over his old job yeah I mean made fun of
them they laughed at them said no right
to be a personality exactly right they
just they absolutely crapped all of them
so again when you don't respect other
people at all on a personal level it's
hard for me to respect you it's it
really all comes down to like Mike I got
no issues with Mike yeah I mean I think
Mike is not as good as he once was like
I said it's just what I'm saying that's
just like you know I don't think Eli
Manning's as good as it once was
deal with it okay but yeah when you
start to do that stuff and then yeah
just too many stories about the way he
treats people it's hard for me to defend
this is all I'm gonna say when Jay Leno
left it was a celebration for him he was
a blue-collar guy hard-working with an
automobile collection a big chin and an
understanding of the heartbeat of
America yeah when he nudged Conan out we
never saw him like that again he was a
capitalist manipulating business the
narcissist approached them outright but
the thing about Francesa is we've always
thought that about your process you're
right him being the odell he knows he's
a diva
he just can't like see the diva and
other people and be okay with them being
right it's like projected he's
projecting yes I just think you guys
like weird sports radio in New York well
we do definitely what you like you like
caller based radio where the callers
don't even get their opinions out
because by the time they said and and
you know France s about Matt Harvey he
goes and in a call man heart and it's
like you there's no discussion he's
getting yelled at by this guy for three
hours and I love it agreed I don't get
it
great with it you're right there is
there's it and it wasn't always that way
I mean listen to him sometimes last year
on Sundays when he would do that NFL
show and I was like these NFL opinions
are so wrong but people are just lapping
it up because it's a cult it's just
people back in the day he was the man
yes I mean when it was in the Mike in
the mad dog it was real especially the
wakes New York radio weird from the rest
of the country for anybody else out
there that it's not from New York and
what's to know
New York is unique for what reason and
sports radio a lot of things baseball
baseball wins here in New York
baseball's king the New York he's gonna
learn on the job I was like that's the
dumbest thing you could write just don't
admit it radio I mean even in Boston I
mean this is awesome as the Patriots are
the Red Sox are still king of this I
mean it's just it's the number one thing
to talk about on a daily basis well
because on a daily basis we get to go
whether or not the manager made the
right decision actly right he's always a
talking point the the Andy Pettitte is a
starting pitcher clip made the rounds
yesterday on France that's a Twitter I
don't know if you guys remember that
conversation but like someone called in
and suggested Andy Pettitte come out of
the bullpen and France that's a hung up
on them and then just yelled into the
microphone for 30 seconds it's the only
thing that doesn't lessen as it's gone
on like the impact is still there like a
Francesa rant about nothing you guys
still get excited now you guys just got
a weird grin on your face because it is
it's part of our the way I think Josh
and I grew up Connor
we had him on our draft coverage it's
part he said when when he heard for
instance of talking about the Mets a
calm came over him like he felt like
again yeah we're doing a mess today
alright this guy's been partying to save
the derby for later we'll talk to Derby
later talking NHL playoffs with
Nicoletti later Yankees calls for a four
o'clock hour just be Francesa for the
whole podcast why I would like you to
sign off today with Francesa with your
good evening
good evening all right so one thing that
is interesting we were talking about the
the nonsense that happens after the
draft it came out of Browns executive
part of the reason he didn't like Rosen
he was in an airport and the UCLA
volleyball coach was there and he said
what do you think about Rosen and the
volleyball coach said something about
Josh rose and bothered me that was a
story that came out after the draft then
Baker Mayfield agent is around or you go
to the Baker man this is like this isn't
that crazy is insane talked about this
though how it's such a conservative
weird culture in the NFL they judge
books by their cover on a daily basis
sorry two in a row it's also the bias
that that's allowed to come in because
of a random person I don't know Baker
Baker Mayfield's agent is making the
rounds and I'd like to tell everyone out
there that understands how the media
works the agent is going to talk up his
guy all the time so when he says that
the Patriots one of the trade up to to
the Jets were definitely taking him at
three we have multiple people in this
office that have friends in the Jets
that are saying that was not the case
but it makes the headline because the
last week has been justifying the Baker
Mayfield pick exactly right every story
that I'm hearing the Patriots if the
Patriots are gonna trade up what did I
say if they were gonna take Lamar it's
automatic validation MOBOTIX who to
trade up then he was the one we are not
going to know until he's getting hit in
the face in week one of the NFL season
but the Baker Mayfield agent story it's
just it's validation is valid you're
you're exactly right I thought of you
right away when I saw it too because I
was like oh they just they happen to
pick the Patriots too huh desolation
right because the Patriots you're right
everybody's gonna go oh well they
probably know something they're better
at it than we are right no yep I know
they passed on Brady five times in one
draft but they know him better than we
so but my big thing there with two would
be to first of all there's no way New
England's gonna trade up to number two
for Baker Mayfield no way listen if he
fell let's just start with the trade
conversation which some people thought
like if Cleveland doesn't take him I
know the Jets weren't taking him they
were taking Donald then Rosen those are
the top two guys in the board know it
know it so that
so then it was gonna be where does he go
and it was always kind of like if Miami
doesn't take him in 11 Elway likes him
at 5 yeah like what but it was he was
the guy that people thought he could
maybe fall because there was this oh we
think Elway like some and we've heard
gates like some but there was nothing
definitive there so I do think New
England probably did their homework 1
because they were like damn maybe if he
is on the board at 18 let's get a get a
good closer look at the kid yeah see
buddy's like at the end of the day what
they're really doing is doing what New
England always does and they are Garrett
gathering inventory that's what New
England does New England's not even
formation exactly they're not thinking
about 2017-18 Baker Mayfield they're the
kind of organization that goes damn he's
a first-round Talent we haven't been
around him at all we're gonna need a
quarterback in the next three to four
years let's get some inventory on what
this guy is like in person maybe even
get a workout so we can have a baseline
wouldn't a Tom Brady conversation his
career is over
and maybe Cleveland gave up on Baker
Mayfield and he's on the street we know
what we're getting that's how smart they
are up there so people are going crazy
out of the fact with the agent doing
that same thing as Malcom Butler the
agent could say that because he knows
Gold Belichick is never gonna come out
and go know that agents stupid he's
wrong that's never happened
Reed we had him what we had them graded
as a third-round pick yeah I mean that's
not gonna happen new wing so they're the
easiest team to say that - because
Bill's not gonna give the media the type
of anything to set the record straight
he doesn't care what you say go ahead
whatever I would use the Patriots for
everything exactly I'd be like Bill
Belichick loves Darius guys he's never
gonna get on Malcom Butler
Malcolm baller broke a rule with the
team he's just he's not gonna make it
public and Malcolm could say he's
innocent all he wants
bill is just gonna let it go on and he's
not gonna say that it's just the way
bill goes I don't know if you do left
goes PR for agents but wouldn't it have
been smarter for the agent to plant this
anonymously use the media have them
attribute it to an anonymous source
instead of Baker's engineer messing up
because wow that his guys been drafted
number one yeah now he's a power agent
now he's trying to get guys for next
year he has to build up his name just
like Jordan Palmer does look a few years
ago
was the quarterback guy that we all knew
George Whitefield yeah Johnny Manziel
didn't pan out George Whitefield fell
off
Jordan Palmer it's name or the Asians in
it for himself Jordan Palmer there's a
reason why Jordan Palmer's handing the
ball to Josh Allen before every throw
because he's building his brand building
his brand this agent is trying to get
other top guys and going man I can get
you the Patriots I can get you in here I
got Johnny Manziel he's got to build his
name I only wrote down his agent because
I don't play that game well I know what
PR you trying to get I honestly thought
to like you know this is like it
benefits him and his client of course in
Baker Mayfield I also thought just the
Cleveland and the Alonzo Highsmith you
know press conference that I unless it
made me think like men did Cleveland
call Baker Mayfield agent to to make
sure he goes around and spread some of
these things because of the backlash
that Baker was the number one pick and
all that so they need to win over the
fan base right we kind of felt a little
bit about this and I'm just gonna we're
gonna take you behind the curtain here
for Simms in left Co we talked about the
Arizona Cardinals actually wanting Josh
out instead of Josh Rosen bleacher
report pushed a little bit and your
first thought was I'm not a really big
fan of this because I don't want to hurt
Josh Rosen yeah the true thing is is if
Josh Rosen plays pretty well that's all
that matters yeah it's got to be a
little bit weird to know that you're
going to a team that didn't want you
first yeah but you've kind of felt bad
because you know he was my second
favorite quarterback of the draft I was
just telling you something that I knew
that went on in the NFL I mean that's
that's all I was trying to say Josh
Rosen certainly has all the tools to be
successful yes we know that it's the
crappy part of the job like yeah but
again peel the curtain back when Josh
said social is going to push this quote
and say that I mean my reaction was like
okay like I mean I know that's the the
price of doing business that's what we
do but it does make me feel bad because
I don't want to take it shot it's not a
shot at Josh Rose no not at all you know
and again to what would like to me and I
also think with Josh Rosen like hey
listen you're not the only guy in the
locker room that you weren't the first
choice that they wanted you can still
pan out be the guy whatever even David
just matter right the Arizona Cardinals
it's on the All or Nothing series they
wanted Ameer Abdullah right and they
couldn't get in Detroit Johnson the best
player on the team was not wanted
Cardinals doesn't mean the hairnet told
me he kind of wanted a Ken Dorsey he gay
like he basically we were out having a
private workout with he just like it was
the offseason spring we had done OTAs
and it was a day I was in there and I
had found out from the team itself that
basically Gruden didn't draft me that
Rich McKay drafted me he was running the
draft and he did it and Gruden we were
kind of out there one day and he was
basically first of all he was
complimenting me too because this was at
the time period where they were going
holy [ __ ] Chris is kind of good and I'm
not trying to Pat myself on the back
ninety throwing for speed but I made
some throws in our first OTAs we're like
you know got veterans were you know
waxing politically so now he's not there
am i bro I did all that right and I like
one of my first completions ever it was
like a 20 yard out route on John Lynch
and he was this is the post Super Bowl
you know bucks they didn't want any
completions on them in practice and I
made a few great throws and man John
Lynch I can remember coming up the
feeling what did you see why didn't you
throw that I can't believe you threw
that I was in the right position and
been up against Brad Johnson for the
last two years but but so Groody must at
this point going like basically you're
out in the field that I was hitting
garbage cans that was part of my stack
garbage cans he would throw me through
wreaths
I'd have to hit the garbage cans and he
was kind of like man who man on target
on target good throw throw then we just
started having a man talking he said you
know I kind of wanted Ken Dorsey just
cuz I thought he was smart and things
like that and he showed me I was like oh
he wanted Ken Dorsey more than me I mean
I'm on TV are you [ __ ] kidding me
did you see Ken Dorsey Ken Dorsey men
would be like 33 and one yeah that was
one that is one decision I will always
look back at and go damn I should have
gone to the you you in the same high
school recruiting class too and he went
to Miami because I took Miami off the
list I mean I did you take Miami awful I
just I couldn't when I went to Miami I
was excited like my a the um I grew up
with the you write the greatest
assemblance balance right Louis all
Michael Irvin when I was 8 and 12 those
they have beat Ohio State if they were
the quarter but so and it's the you but
I go into Butch Davis office he's got a
jersey with my name and number on I mean
they move spits into a jar I'm watching
the spring
practice practice that I'm like damn who
is this running back me and my dad I
could still remember we'd look at each
other and go who the hell is that the
first play of full life conduct let's
guess a little open know it's either
gonna be Frank or Willis McGahee R
Clinton Portis I'm gonna none of the
above you're missing somebody else
gigantic you're missing somebody else
gigantic better than all those guys
you're forgetting Jamal Lewis I don't
know no you're really forgetting Frank
Gore Clinton Portis Willis McGahee and
they did have four head you're in jail
Oh bust through the line of scrimmage on
the first play of the scrimmage and he
ran somebody over I mean my dad looked
at each other and I was like holy Sh I
was like who is this guy and but I
didn't go because it's not the total
college atmosphere there miami
especially at that time like their
facilities are really known as the old
Orange Bowl old facilities and really
they only get a huge crowd when they
played the Florida State's of the world
the big games but like when Boston
College comes in the Orange Bowl would
be like 20,000 people yeah and that was
like damn I mean my spring game at Texas
is gonna get you know 40,000 so what
that doesn't make sense I couldn't I
couldn't swallow that pill it's
interesting I don't know if you'd be a
good Miami guy I think Texas was the
Rams I think I would've been in trouble
yeah yeah you questions you still trying
to make that 5:30 train no I wanted to
say that with all these quarterbacks and
all that my quarterback Carson Wentz you
know what he did
all right donating half a million
dollars to Haiti to bring lights and
Wi-Fi in sports fields so at least you
have one good role model now talk about
the other girl model in your life that's
not so good
Kanye West oh you want to go there no I
really I don't want to be I don't want
to do this at all I don't want to do it
too much hi there I just I'm just
annoyed by them that's all I could say
hey little teaser if you've a comedian
can we give out an unedited
Kanye bleacher report
thinks that Kanye is the dumbest person
ever and he hates all of what he stands
for and I am trying to reason and
dumbest person ever I'm trying to reason
what Kanye is trying to say because I
don't find him to be an efficient
communicator and I see it because I
think that I'm a little crazy too and I
think that I resonated with but I
understand why he's making people so
uncomfortable and upsetting so many
people but I also see what he's trying
to accomplish so Blake bortles the 70th
rank whatever I want to talk about it
forget it I feel like I got a muzzle and
forget it
don't worry do you think that's how you
feel
those are my intentions two people that
are not with a team right now and two
different reasons why I think they're
now with a team one is Dez Bryant the
Dallas executive came out said he
couldn't win one-on-ones anymore do you
think des is actually gonna get signed
to a team and is going to take like a
training camp like injury or do you
think teams are looking at their wide
receiving core like I don't see any buzz
right now for them no there's not gonna
be buzz I think that's war was the one
team right Baltimore was the one team I
think there's teams out there that are
certainly got that got him on their
board but they're gonna go through the
first OTAs and maybe a mini camp to go
we need so let me see is this
second-year receiver Cincinnati that's
my that's my I know you know he when you
think about it who could it be
right I mean there's a team's pull the
teams Baltimore Arizona Green Bay yeah
Green Bay certainly not Baltimore excuse
me Arizona Cincinnati Green Bay I don't
really know who else needs a wide
receiver that yeah I mean I don't think
they're bringing them in Indianapolis
it's gotta be a certain type of culture
I know like the Tennessee Titans I can't
think of them doing it either they can
either tell us Ben and Iseult tweeted
out why is he not getting a chance as
like a nanquan Bolden role like a nice
tough slot receiver because he's never
shown the ability to run and run those
type of routes or be a slot guide at
this point because of the offense the
option offense they ran in Dallas it is
definitely and he didn't because at his
time in his prime he was so gifted you
could just throw him out on one side and
basically be like oh you got covered we
can still throw you a jump ball whatever
it may be pushing too much stop exactly
you make people miss whatever yes
but the Scout that you I mean I know we
talked about this that is the number one
problem that with Dez Bryant he's been
saying for two yeah he can't be
one-on-one consistently his ability to
scare corners with the go route which is
so important on an outside receiver does
not exist so when you're not scared of
the go route as a corner yeah you just
go I'm gonna stay on this hip because
I'm not worried about him running by me
and that allows the corner to sit on the
shorter stuff the other guy that doesn't
have a team right now is Eric Reid
safety former safety from the San
Francisco 49ers and he has just filed a
collusion case he is getting the same
eight same lawyer as Kaepernick has
because he's saying that the team's the
NFL are colluding against him which
really means that adopting a coordinated
approach to Shawn a player who was
deemed bad for business because of their
role in the protest agreed with
everything he said the coordinated
approach that's the one thing I can't
sign off with him on it's gonna be
interesting because it's very well
documented he went to the Bengals yeah
the Bengals said will you stop
protesting and I can't guarantee that
and they said we're not offering you
right right but the true thing is is in
a business does that count as a
coordinated approach you know that's a
butch has to be like Cincinnati called
Baltimore Baltimore called Seattle and
we're not we're all not gonna sign yeah
right okay good that's why they got all
the lawyers they got all like the phone
records and stuff from all the teams yes
I just have a hard time thinking that
the owners would be ever dumb enough if
those conversations did happen to put
them on text or make phone calls and I'd
really don't think the conversations has
happened because I think you have a
bunch of you know billionaires who own a
football team who the bottom line is
their money and they look at those guys
and just go damn I'm scared that that's
gonna hurt my money should Eric Reid be
on a team definitely he's just starting
on the felt safety he's not like one of
the best but he's definitely should be
one of the two starting safeties on the
32 NFL he's definitely one of the 64
best safeties in the sport I'm sure
teams are gonna go to camp they're gonna
look at their safeties and then they're
gonna think about it yeah could getting
the same lawyer as Kaepernick prevent
him from getting on a team yeah it could
yeah I don't think that's gonna help him
in this case because I didn't get do
they're gonna lump them together in the
same thought process of golf
this is distraction yeah this is I've
we're gonna ask we're gonna have to
answer questions about you know the
social wrongness of the world how dare
we and I'm just gonna end it with this
discussion this is your man Mike Florio
I don't know who wrote the article and
pro football tried but in the article it
said because of his role in the anthem
protest yeah I talked about this with
our Quality Control Department and I
would like everyone to understand why
that sentence is so scary he was not
protesting the anthem I understand that
it's like a hashtag it's like calling it
deflategate yeah we're calling it anthem
protests you know exactly what I'm
talking about right these guys were
never protesting the anthem they were
doing their protest during the anthem
there are two different things and if
you go yeah yeah yeah it's semantics
then I'm gonna go yeah you're putting
things on two people that didn't
actually happen that's just when I read
things ago learn how to use your words
because you're putting a problem on
someone that shouldn't actually exist
exactly right well said thank you for yo
is totally for the fight just I don't
want to throw him under the bus or
anything he's totally for the fight I
just think it's kind of understanding
the way that words guide right uh one
last big left go point that I'm seeing I
think that the NFL looked at the NBA and
they saw the way that the NBA was
globalizing their sport and the NFL said
alright we got to go to Mexico we got to
go to London we're gonna start there I
had someone in Instagram DM saying why
don't they ever have games in Hawaii
there's no monetary gain in Hawaii
they've been in Hawaii they've tried to
get the sport big there they need to go
south to Mexico and to Mexican Americans
that live in American North America
United States and then also London
because they gotta figure out a way to
get to Europe which they could have just
kept nfo Europe going all those years
really right but what I'm noticing right
now is the NFL is trying to monetize
London where I feel like before they are
trying to spread in London and there's a
few things that's making me think that
one the London Games tickets went on
sale and were sold out the next day it's
led to an uproar in a lot of European
NFL fans because they were unable to buy
tickets and when they so who bought them
fell when well what do you mean they
just that's how popular our product is
on second uh I'm trying to I don't wanna
say this incorrectly on second sites all
the tickets have popped back up with
much higher ticket prices so either the
United States fans are buying it and
reselling it back to London fans or the
NFL is a part of this somehow that's
what's being accused right now from a
number of writers in London but from
what I'm seeing and what I'm reading is
a lot of fans in Europe and in London
are going you're gonna charge us 700
pounds to go to this random game between
the Eagles and Jaguars when I'm a Bills
fan and for 700 pounds I can get a
flight and a ticket in Buffalo it's just
it's very interesting what's happening
right now and then when you couple it
with the fact that shod cons come out
recently yeah shod con the owner of the
Jaguars is trying to buy part of Wembley
Stadium and his argument is look
everyone wants to be in London I just
think that I should get a part of this
because I've been with Jaguars and we're
trying to be there shod Khan is trying
to make money right now and he's trying
to get this done and he told the BBC
that if he owns the Wembley he's gonna
try and push for bigger events including
the Superbowl just like Baker Mayfield's
a gym he's not trying to get this Super
Bowl there this man is looking at
Jacksonville going if you're gonna force
me to go to London and I need real
estate in London the the NFL the biggest
problem I go back to what Mark Cuban
said a few years ago pigs get fat and
hogs get slaughtered the NFL is not okay
with just expanding into the rest of the
world just to expand they're trying to
get their money back already and I think
it's gonna a lien ate a lot of those
fans out there and ruin a lot of the
good-natured spreading that they've been
doing and I'm just seeing something that
I think is gonna happen in the future
because when you start asking for money
back yeah it's a problem yeah you need
to allow time to grow and I don't think
the NFL will allow time to grow well
just something I'm seeing with a lot of
like strings being pulled yeah well yeah
I mean we're not you weren't all over
the place I I didn't know anything about
that subject and you explained it to me
to where I have questions I mean first
of all with the ticket like the ticket
but he's do they have like computer
programs they can just buy these things
up like on the internet say no I know
that like the case with a lot of big
shoe releases right I get compliments
from everyone here when a new Nike or a
new Yeezy or a new Jordan comes out
they're sold out right and then I go on
Instagram yeah and I see a kid with 700
pairs because they have BOTS that they
buy that do all this would not be
surprising I just know that the retail
sites they're up in the price 500 pounds
of ticket and then the real yeah they
shouldn't that's it's messed up I don't
like that it man meaning to police the
Internet holy crap that's that's bad so
that is an example of following the
money but I want to give two examples of
following what you love first is Arian
Foster is a musician yes and his name is
Bobby Fino and I watched an entire like
documentary on tidal about him and we
saw I saw some bleacher report employees
like Christina tapper in like a
listening party with like DZ's and Miro
and I said let me check out this guy's
album dude blew me away yeah Bobby Fino
he has a line on one of the songs where
he's like I'm 29 and I don't got to be
an inmate or something like that and I
thought it was a shot at Bob McNair and
the Texans but just check out Bobby Fino
I came away very impressed the other
thing is an itunes comment that I found
that kind of got me a little emotional
so this is from FV io l 743 do work to
get what emotional or vadoma good hey
guys been a dedicated listener for the
last year absolutely loved the podcast I
look forward to listening to you guys on
the way to work every Tuesday and
Thursday I just want to take a quick
second to thank Adam for something he
said on the pod a few months ago you
mentioned getting inundated with emails
and DMS asking if you call people and
speak with them about how they can get
into the business what you said next
helped me get my dream job you said that
if you want somebody's help bring
something to the table do some work
ahead of time I had an interview the
next week so I started grinding I spent
maybe six hours creating materials for
my interview I walked in there destroyed
the interview and all my way out I left
them my materials that I created they
called me the next day and offered me
the job
just to put this into context I
graduated in December
my master's in school counseling to get
a job in this field in Pennsylvania is
extremely difficult with no experience
yet they gave me the job I attribute
this to your advice so thank you so much
keep doing what you're doing you guys
are awesome we're getting people paid
we're getting people jobs and now we're
gonna party at Phil's house and it's
gonna be awesome other than you
supporting Kanye you're awesome the
other than that you're that's just
that's a [ __ ] on your armor sir he's
you don't check all the boxes for me
he's the best musician in the last 20
years he's a great musician right yeah I
have like for me I I kind of go like
this it's like everyone's like all Bella
checks he's so mean he's so ruthless he
doesn't care about anybody and all that
stuff and it's like to create great
things you really need to not care about
anybody and I've kind of let's go if I
agree with that I don't know there are a
lot of great people who've done great
things were able to like people not
everyone has to do that right but I've
you know Steve Jobs was like completely
ruthless I get it he didn't have to be
like that but I think when you get that
big and you're above 30,000 feet and the
air gets thinner and you look down at a
lot of people you kind of go you don't
understand what it takes to get to this
level I think you get separated from
humans and so what upsets regular humans
you don't even comprehend anymore
because you're like doesn't make sense
I'm garrison I know I just I don't think
he reads the news that's my own I think
so - all right so the Kanye's special
will be coming soon that was a lot of
fun thank you to boomer and Phil Simms
for coming in we are going to be having
possibly some guests next week that are
very cool and we're just gonna keep it
going so keeping us up on social keep
making the conversation fun foursomes
just for fun jerk
and for the lef koe man thank you guys
as always thank you for following us
follow us on Instagram at Simpson love
Co Twitter subscribe on iTunes and
YouTube share share share like like like
all that nonsense love you guys so much
we're gonna keep kicking ass we'll see
you next week
peace